this works should be going live
but people will not know that we are
live
but that's okay i've got dave here
dave is patiently waiting while i set up
all this nonsensical streaming stuff
let's see here folks if i can copy that
and now i'm going to put this out there
let's see if people hear me there we go
got you we got me and i see you dave
how are you today sorry for all these
technical difficulties
that's fine this is very frustrating and
it is of course
your very first live stream i think
is that right this is my first on-camera
interview ever
really that's amazing i would have
thought you had done so many well it's a
thrill to be with you
for many reasons uh one of which is that
i've greatly enjoyed being
on the geeks guide to the galaxy for
which you act as proprietor and
i am thrilled that you agreed to come on
the into the impossible podcast we
we noted of course that we have several
friends in common and guests in common
and uh and so for that reason
alone it would be worth having you on
but uh i'm fascinated
sorry could i just are you are we
definitely alive right now because i'm
looking at the
youtube and i'm not seeing yeah it's i
had to switch
the the my streaming software switched
us
from the scheduled thing from the
scheduled
uh stream to now we're on a different
stream
i'm going to tweet it out now and then
you should receive that
and maybe you could retweet it the
actual link that we're on
is being moved over to another youtube
link so let me put that out
okay i've just been talking to the
people in the chat
um yeah
hold on one second and we'll get this
going something how about the streaming
software
and i have no idea what it was but um
we're gonna make it through we're gonna
get through
now it's on uh twitter so those of you
who want to re-forward
my uh geeks guide to the galaxy live
stream with david curtley
please do that well though we have over
20 people watching right now and people
giving us thumbs up so we are definitely
live
and we should begin right now so dave
uh where are you joining us from
actually don't know where you're located
where's your home base your base of
operations
uh so i currently live in san marcos
texas which is just
uh 30 minutes or so south of austin my
girlfriend is doing an mfa in creative
writing at texas state so we moved here
about a year ago
ah very good so you and i have
done one podcast together this of course
your first
live appearance of any kind but
hopefully it won't be your last i don't
think it will be your last unless you're
so turned off by this experience
but we had a great time last time and
i'll put in the notes at some point uh
link to our previous interview but uh i
am many things a big fan of yours
and also i am a patron and i recommend
that all my listeners also
support the work that dave does and the
geeks guide to the galaxy
which is uh which is a wired magazine
product so that it isn't officially
endorsed by the
uh i guess it's as close to the holy
bible as you can get
to geeks nerds and dweebs like me
uh but it is a thrill to have dave on i
want to first start off since your
podcast for my listeners who may not
know
is predominantly uh focused although not
entirely so by any means
on science fiction science fantasy uh
speculative culture
and so on and so forth i want to ask you
uh
about in keeping with that theme what is
your origin
story how did you come to get into this
world of
science fiction and then specifically
podcasting
and ultra specifically on the geeks
guide itself so take it away dave what
is your
mythological origin story the farther
away the home planet the better
okay so that's kind of a long story but
so
quickly my my parents are both
scientists
um my dad's a physicist and my mom has a
phd in chemistry
and they both worked at ibm at the ibm
thomas j watson lab in yorktown heights
new york
so you know the watson computer that won
jeopardy was developed there and is
named after that facility
and so they're both lifelong science
fiction fans
and um so i was just raised as a science
fiction
fan you know all the books they read to
me growing up were all science fiction
books and stuff like that
um yeah
uh and talk about how did you come into
podcasting what about your education
tell us a little bit more about the back
story
okay so in uh in high school you know i
was writing science fiction stories my
whole life
and i started publishing stuff when i
was 16
and so by the time i got to college i
had won
a bunch of contests maybe i don't know
maybe 10 or so national contests
and uh when i was a freshman in college
i won the asimov award which was an
award
it's now called the dell magazines award
but it's an award for undergraduate like
the best
science fiction story submitted by an
undergraduate
and so that they flew me down to fort
lauderdale
um for a sort of a convention and that
was kind of my introduction to
science fiction fandom um and then
another big thing that happened in
college was i attended the clarion
writers workshop in 1999
which is you know it's a six-week summer
workshop where you get to work with a
lot of
big-name science fiction authors and
then i started um you know i kept
publishing stuff i published about 30
short stories in different magazines and
anthologies
and i was really um plugged into the
science fiction scene in new york city
uh the two big events in new york city
are the kgb bar readings
and the new york review of science
fiction reading series and so through
those i met a bunch of people
and um including john joseph adams who's
my best friend
he's now a big science fiction editor
and so he and i started the podcast
together in 2010
uh it's kind of a long story i don't
know how much how much detail do you
want on
on the early days of geeks guide to the
galaxy i'd like to know how you came
uh to get approached to do it uh how you
started uh getting connected to wired
magazine that's a dream gig
for any one in the podcast space uh tell
us about that how did you come to
acquire
such a powerful benefit uh so i
uh you know i so you know when i was
growing up there were no podcasts
obviously
and so when podcasts came around i was
just
uh completely mesmerized by them and i
just listened i was listening to
podcasts all day because
finally there were shows about things i
was actually interested in which was
never the case really when i was growing
up with television and so
um so john and i had been frustrated for
a long time
and it's probably kind of hard to
imagine now but back then
so this would be 2010 so kind of in the
years leading up to 2010
there were really no positive uh
depictions of science fiction geeks
in popular culture uh and so the big
thing that
that really kind of pissed us off was
there was this documentary called
trekkies
and the whole thrust of trekkies is kind
of like look at these freaks
they're so weird look at how you know
nerdy they are and stuff
and so we were kind of like wouldn't it
be great if there was just a
documentary or something that showed
science fiction fans as kind of cool and
normal and i think you know
if you've listened to the show i think
most of the people that we have on
especially the recurring guests are
fun interesting people that you would
want to hang out with you know
and so um so we were kind of like well
we can't do a
documentary we just don't have the skill
set to do that but i was really really
into podcasts
and so we and actually around that same
time john had edited an anthology called
the living dead this is when those
zombies were just it was just going nuts
with how popular zombies were
and so we were just going around to all
these like you know horror clubs and
things uh promoting his anthology and
one of the promotional things we did was
we appeared on jim poyne's hour of the
wolf show on wbai which is this uh it's
a science fiction show it's about two
hours it's
it's at like two in the morning or
something and
um and so we we did that
and uh we kind of come out and it's like
the sun is just coming up you know
and um and and john was like oh i wish
we could keep talking this is so much
fun i wish we could keep talking about
this
and i said well you know if we had our
own podcast we could just talk about it
forever you know no one could ever stop
us
and so um yeah so we just started um
at the time actually john was um he was
writing articles for tor.com which is
the website of tor books
and all the sort of people who worked
for tor and people in science fiction
were all playing this
zombie shooter game called left for dead
which is a four player co-op game from
valve
and so they would all be on their
headsets like talking as they're
shooting zombies
and so he was you know playing this game
with one of the editors i guess the main
editor
editor at the time of tour.com and kind
of just pitched him on the idea of us
doing a podcast for them
and they agreed and so we started doing
it for tor
and then we did it for them for i think
about six or seven months
and then they they had like a staff
change and budget cuts and stuff and so
they dropped the podcast
and in the meantime john had been
talking to anderlee newitz of io9
uh which was gawker's at the time was
gawker's science and technology futurism
blog science fiction and so uh so she
had listened to one of the episodes and
she really liked it so then we moved
over to io9
and then it was a similar thing after
about a year they had budget cuts etc
and so then they dropped us and then
john had been somehow he'd met this guy
lewis wallace who worked at wired
and um and they were looking because
they felt like they didn't really do any
book coverage
and so he he kind of brought us on um
because we would be doing book coverage
and he you know he listened to the show
and liked it and then that was
probably 2012 so so i think
we've been on wired for eight years now
oh wow so
i'm getting some questions just in the
youtube realm
from my listeners uh who are a fan of
yours
and they're curious about other uh
podcasters that straddle
the science fiction science fantasy
science fact
nonfiction world like isaac arthur um
uh john michael gautier do you have uh
real
you know connections with those in the
youtube podcast sci-fi
science space or is it uh basically
you know nowadays more or less a one-man
show right
uh i do know isaac i mean i know of
isaac arthur i've never talked to him
uh his i've looked at his youtube
channel it looks amazing but i've never
i haven't really gotten into it
um the people kind of in this space i
mean the people i know are kind of more
on the science fiction side
but um in terms of people who straddled
the two worlds i mean i did do a show
with rose evolith and
i'm gonna blank on his name eric
something he uh they do
the he does the um
it's called imaginary worlds it's a
really really popular science
and he and they both have backgrounds in
public radio but he does imaginary
worlds and she does
um a future
this is this was several years ago now
that i talked to them
um uh yeah
i'm blanking on the title but the
premise of the show is that the they um
she imagines a different future scenario
in every episode
and then talks to different scientists
and science fiction writers about
you know what that scenario would be
like um
and um and then yeah most of the other
people in podcasting i sort of
know were you know people who run like
escape pod and pseudopod and
uh podcastle and and and those sorts of
things i mean those are the first couple
of
things that come to mind uh so reminder
everybody out there we're talking to
the proprietor of the geeks guide to the
galaxy none other than david barkertley
uh who has become a friend and i've
become a patron
at the ripe old sum of uh one bitcoin
per month
uh you're getting all that bitcoin edge
that i'm sending you aren't you
uh i encourage you to do that too i put
the website
of david's podcast uh
podcastgeeksguideshow.com it's up there
there's a link to
the crowdfunding page please do
subscribe to the podcast
you'll see it's got 800 to 1000 reviews
on itunes very very
uh spectacular stuff and i want to talk
about that
but i really i want to get your reaction
to this and you can't say this about
yourself so i have to say it about you
i trust you won't mind me praising you
too much but one thing that really
distinguishes
you in my opinion is that you have
voracious curiosity
you have this insatiable thirst to know
things and have
very respectful dialogue even with
people that are controversial
as we you and i talked about on our show
when i was on your podcast
but the other thing that i'm wondering
if you'll agree with me or not is that
you have a superpower
like many science fiction avatars do
and that in my estimation is your
ability to read a book
and actually consume material uh
incredibly rapidly is that uh is that an
accurate statement or would you say that
uh that you're just kind of faking the
depth of your
of your sincerity when you have guests
on the show
no i actually i read every book i mean
you know when we started the show we
were doing it every week and we were
doing both an interview and a discussion
every week
and back then there was no way i could
read all the books so
you know i sort of felt like i was doing
okay if i read the first half of a novel
and usually if you read the first half
of a novel you know you're probably not
going to talk about the second half in
an interview anyway because you don't
want to spoil it
but i've read every but i just i don't
want to be the guy who
um interviews people about books but
never finishes any books you know i mean
i want to finish the books and add them
to my goodreads
thing um so i finished every single book
that we've covered
uh for years now i i'd have to go back
and check but for something like
six or seven years um i've had an
unbroken street
i'm unfortunately not a very fast reader
um i think i can read non-fiction i can
read non-fiction pretty fast and without
too much trouble
but novels i actually read pretty slowly
um
i sort of and it's kind of like i used
to be able to read novels really fast
but i sort of
actually trained when i was studying
writing i actually trained myself to
really pay attention to every word and
really carefully study every sentence
structure and every mark of punctuation
and i just can't really break that habit
now so
and actually you know because like
because but i mean so how i how i read
all the books is just devoting an
enormous amount of time to it so i mean
you know i work on the podcast probably
i don't know 14 to 16 hours a day seven
days a week
you know for the last 10 years wow um
and so a lot of the books and it just
gets boring just sitting there
like reading a book for 16 hours you
know not doing anything else
really so all the a lot of the books i
actually i actually read them out loud
because that's like more fun for me i
feel like i'm doing something i'm
performing but then obviously then it
takes you know five times as long to
to read the book but um i just kind of
have to at this after ten years like i
kind of kind of have to do stuff like
that just to keep myself
you know engaged right but no i'm
definitely not faking i i
have read all the books and you know and
all the life i've underlined everything
i want to talk about and written notes
in the margins and stuff so so that's
all
that's all that's all real that's great
yeah i mean i
i was thinking about it and i actually
picked up a technique
um from another podcaster named james
altitude whose birthday it is today
and if you've never had him on your show
you definitely should he's a huge
science fiction fan
he's a extremely popular podcaster
really got me interested in podcasting
you know 10 years ago and i never
started until
really just about a year ago and today's
his birthday
so i thought it would be fitting to kind
of bestow upon you a technique that he
taught me
and it the way that it came about was
really interesting because he was on one
show
i'd been on a show once before and then
he asked me to come back on to talk
specifically just
not about my book anymore but to talk
about the big bang
and when we were talking he said
something like um
or be between the show where i aired
just talking about my book
and the second appearance when i talked
only about the big bang and not about my
book
i uh i had a a chance to listen to him
and he was talking about how he reads
books because he reads a book a week too
for the last 15 years and and uh and
it's just
incredible how he does it and he was
describing this is the way i do it
let's say i'm reading a really boring
book about the big bang
i was just like holy crap he's talking
about losing the nobel prize
but uh he claims he wasn't but he's like
my technique is that
actually for non-fiction books you don't
have to read every word
so what he does for speed reading first
of all he he actually like traces his
finger back and
it's true actually if you ever try this
you could your eyes
if they try if you can't move your eyes
smoothly unless they have a target to
read
uh to fixate upon so in other words if i
tell you to move your eyes only your
eyes
across the scene right now they make
little movements and ophthalmologists
tell me there's a name for that
but if you put your finger up it can
trace the finger and you can actually
read more smoothly
so actually they recommend and he
recommends you move your finger across
the page
to in and it will improve and it does
improve my reading ability in printed
words
uh the other thing he says to do is to
read you know basically
he said like let's say the guy's talking
about the discovery of the cosmic
microwave background
you know another boring stuff yeah
whatever so he says the guy's going to
start off by saying the causing
microwave background was discovered in
1965
and he's going to have like a fact and
then a supporting fact and then
something relate so he's like you really
only have to read the first line and the
last line of every paragraph
but then you can you can apply that to
everything like the first paragraph of
every
book of every chapter that's all you
have to he just went through it and i
don't do that but but nevertheless it
has been
uh some of that has been helpful because
there'll be a lot of times when you know
enough about science
uh even though you're not a professional
scientist that i mean you've done
tremendous reading and cross-referencing
we'll get into some of your
uh some of my favorite interviews that
you've done besides the episode that i
was on of course which is
one of my favorites uh uh but uh but the
way that you read there'll be a lot of
overlap for example you did an interview
with michael shermer
you did an interview with stephen pinker
uh they both have written books about
you know the arc of moral progress
effective mark michael's book was called
that and stevens was called
enlightenment now and they're very
similar and so um
you know my my technique because now i'm
having stephen pinker on the show in a
couple of weeks
and he uh you know i have to read his
book which is like 600 pages long
but i've already read michael's book so
anyway just a little tips and tricks to
accelerate not that you need them
but but it it found i was really i'm so
blown away by your preparation because i
know it's hard for me i read only
a book every 10 days last year and it
almost killed me
uh to do that um of course i have other
things that buy from my
time which you may not including
screaming children that clamor for my
time which is why i was late by the way
to this podcast i am i do try and put in
some time with my kids
in addition to forcing them to watch
into the impossible podcast but this is
a good opportunity
for you guys to do the following please
go to
itunes or wherever you get podcasts sign
up to geek's guide to the galaxy
i i hesitate to do it because you're so
good
and and you really you know you steal a
lot of my thunder
uh but it's the highest highest form of
compliment that i can get to say that i
am emulating
uh your work and your style and and kind
of the meticulosity if that's a word of
what you do so please my fans out there
subscribe to him on twitter i think it's
geek's guide on twitter
follow him as i do and subscribe speaks
galaxy geeksgalaxy okay great
on twitter and he is prolific on
uh podcasting i want to talk to you
about a repurposing of material
you don't pay as much attention to
youtube in fact your interviews are all
single
audio format only and then you upload
sort of an audiogram format to youtube
why
why do you do that why don't you
multipurpose as i'm going to do with
this podcast
i actually do everything in video only
and then i rip the audio
and uh have an intro and outro and put
it up on itunes
what was behind the decision to only do
audio format
uh i mean it was not a strategic
decision i mean it was just like i don't
like the idea of being on camera
honestly um
and so i never really wanted to do a
video show just because i didn't want to
i don't know i don't like people looking
at me um
i don't know it's not like um anything
strategic
i mean it would make obviously video
performs a lot better
i mean when we started it was 2010 and
youtube i don't remember what the state
of youtube was
but i from what i remember there wasn't
a lot on youtube at the time there were
no
certainly nothing like like now if
you're starting now you would think like
oh i gotta do video it just makes sense
but
back then even just doing audio seems
you know like oh this is pretty high
tech you know you can like
download this audio file and listen to
it on your ipod at the time you know
this is pretty this is pretty cool stuff
um and so then
it's mostly just you know i spend so
much time doing the audio show the way
i've always done it there's just no
bandwidth left over
to you know to do anything else um
but i mean i do think about sometimes
like oh this would probably be
more uh accessible or you know reach a
broader
audience if it had if it was uh you know
like a video show on youtube so i might
do that i mean i think the thing is that
when we started the podcast you could um
you could really build a audience for an
audio podcast
because uh it was it was not that hard
to get into the top
of the itunes charts you know i mean
there was a time we got until
i forget what it was but it was like
number 68
overall of all podcasts on itunes you
know
which is incredibly hard to do by the
way yeah
well now like now it now it is yeah um
but um
you know but we would often be in like
the top ten of the literature
um category and stuff like that so we
were building an audience very nicely
um but i think these days like really
the only way to build an audience for a
podcast is you have to appear on more
popular podcasts
or you have to like somehow um appeal to
the youtube algorithm
in a way that it puts your content in
front of people who've never heard of
you before
so um yeah so it's it would be smart the
short answer is it would be smarter to
do what you're
yeah and i'm adjusting i'm happy to help
you uh if you need any
tips or tricks i want to thank my
audience of the into the impossible
podcast we just cracked 20
000 subscribers and we were recently in
the top
10 on itunes and i want to thank my
subscribers and also encourage you
to subscribe to dave's uh channel on
his itunes feed for geek's guide to the
galaxy it's really spectacular
i guess actually the other thing i'll
say about that is that it's much easier
to edit audio
than to edit video at least i i don't
really have any experience editing video
but it certainly seems like it would be
harder
and i edit the things a lot and actually
these days i don't edit them as much as
i used to but for the first
several years i was editing out half of
the stuff we recorded because it was
just boring or like whatever
and so just the thought of doing that in
video seemed very daunting
um and and especially since um a lot of
the people that i interview
are not used to giving interviews i mean
they're they're authors and they don't
give interviews very often and
they're not often very polished and they
really need you know
i'll take something that's an hour long
and then cut it down to 40 minutes and
it's much better at 40 minutes um so
that
just the the ease and practicality of
editing audio was also sort of has also
been a factor of me sticking with audio
so far
yeah well i'm all about and i've been
trying this with the live streams that
we're doing and
having some really nice success with to
really purpose and repurpose in as many
different formats as i can because
you know you don't know if someone will
find it on linkedin
where i've got a nice following or on
facebook or
or instagram where i have almost no
following and
you know but i'd like to to kind of
broadcast it literally
and also these live streams allow me to
take you know take
uh donations for my audience like julian
thank you so much uh five pounds of
british sterling
and that's very lovely no i don't do it
for the for the donations i do it
because
i like to interact with the audience and
get give them a chance to talk to great
thinkers
authors writers we've had on you know
very similar guests as you know
uh but uh but one thing i think that's
unique is i get to
demonstrate they get to interact with
people ranging from
you know yesterday we had on eric
weinstein and garrett lisey for their
first
live stream podcast in in history
together and that was really fun max tag
mark another one so
um it does give you some more options to
kind of repurpose and reach different
groups and i think
you know my wife asked me yesterday like
why are you doing all these you know why
aren't you home more
no no she said oh you know why do you do
it like what's behind it and i said well
i
love communicating this passion that i
have to create
sort of this this university that i wish
i could have gone to
as a young person and part of a
university
is literature it's not only doing
physics it's reading great literature so
behind me you'll see books by david brin
who's a friend and alum of ucsd um
and that's great literature kim stanley
robinson other great literature
also ucsd alum david uh greg and james
benford etc
but i do believe that uh science fiction
is a form of literature so first of all
um let's say you only had one option
would you take
uh to a desert island deserted planet
uh science fiction or science fantasy
which which kind of is closer to your
heart am forcing you to only
choose one
uh well that's very difficult because i
am sort of equally a fan of fantasy and
science fiction i mean
i think that i mean i sort of i think
that science fiction is more important
in a way in terms of dealing with real
science and
getting people to think about the future
so i i definitely think science fiction
is more important in a way
but honestly i would probably well i
mean
the books that i've reread the most are
rogers zolasney's chronicles of amber
which is a
fantasy series i mean there's sort of
some science fictional aspects to it but
mostly it's
it's a sort of epic fantasy
sword and sorcery kind of thing and
that's probably what i would take
you know either that or gene wolf's book
of the new son
which is is also i mean it is is
definitely
science fantasy but um probably more
fantasy than science fiction
um so so i guess that's my answer is
that
if the thing i would take to a island
would be probably
some sort of epic fantasy um but i i
feel that science fiction is kind of
more important
off off the desert island probably yeah
that brings up my next question which is
we know that
science fiction has had influence on
actual science non-fiction or
if you like on actual science uh ranging
from our namesake host arthur c clarke's
you know conceptions of things like
ipads and
and uh certainly the uh geosynchronous
satellites for communication is there
any
because you're so much more of an expert
than i am in fantasy has there ever been
an analog of something in science
fantasy
that percolated its way through either
to culture
or to actual science fact or is that
not really uh you know an example
something has happened
you're asking if there's been a
technological advance that was inspired
by a fantastic
cultural you know like i don't know i
mean there it seems to me that fantasy
the
fantas fantastic aspects of you know
science fiction or science fantasy
itself
you know hasn't necessarily uh had the
influence on technology but maybe on
culture
i don't know maybe or or is it a lagging
indicator is fantasy
like star trek was you know kind of
revolutionary for some social
aspects that it took on you know right
ra in terms of taking on confronting
racism and some extent
uh but that might have been reactive or
retroactive
is there anything that like foreshadowed
like i don't know something in the
future that then became part of culture
if not part of technology or was that
just way off base
well i don't know i mean the first thing
that comes to mind i don't know if this
is exactly what you're asking but you
know i just did an episode on apple ii
games yeah
and i think you can't understate the
influence that
tolkien had on computer nerds
you know there was a line in this book i
just read where it was like every single
computer hacker on earth the first
program they wrote was trying to
transplant their dnd campaign on
and see if you could get it going on the
computer um
and so i don't know how computer games
or computer
software might have developed if there'd
been no lord of the rings but
it seems like you just can't you almost
can't imagine computer games without
lord of the rings
um so uh i mean obviously lord of the
rings was
incredibly influential on lots of things
but that seems to me that's the first
thing that strikes me as
sort of an intersection of uh technology
being influenced by a fantasy novel
ah very good uh okay so we got questions
from the audience um
what about isaac asimov of the hard
science fiction
versus soft science fiction or more
fantasy
or within a given authors
especially within a genre but but within
a given author's
you know uh ubra as they say uh what
you know what would you say you
gravitate more towards is the
fantasies of the fiction of someone like
an asimov or
um or in general do you like
you know kind of very modest amounts of
fantasy
in your science fiction
i mean i like all kinds of stuff i mean
i like as i've gotten older i found
myself gravitating more and more to hard
science fiction and
you know outer space and you know
authors who are scientists are
well-versed in science
um just because i don't know it's just
different i mean there's just so much
fantasy now that it kind of
um you know i i've seen like so much
fantasy and
and hard science fiction is a little bit
more uh
you know exclusive or rare that uh it
kind of has been interesting me more
but i mean my my sort of favorite
uh type of fiction i could sort of trace
um there's there's a sort of like
a a branch of fantasy that kind of runs
from
um edgar riceborough's um princess of
mars
through jack vance through um
you know yeah like roger zelazny uh
through
gene wolfe uh through to george r martin
um and i think that you know if i had to
pick one branch
it would be that uh the sort of the
romance in the in the classic sense so
not like in the contemporary publishing
category of a romance novel
but in the sense of um you know
that the fantas that it's very you know
like the planetary romance that there's
something just beautiful about these
alien environments that strikes a chord
in your soul
and the the fantasy is about
evoking some emotional response uh not
just about being kind of
weird or different for its own sake yeah
um
so yeah there would be that uh so a
friend of mine brian pendley
is asking uh he's talking about his
uh his interest and he's very interested
in science he's part you know very
frequent
uh participate in all my physics streams
he says he wants to write a
tolkien-esque
story and he knows the ending he has
some battle sequences in store and some
characters it's the doggone
beginning that's hard for him to come up
with do you have any tips
for brian who's aspiring to write a talk
and ask story
i mean it's funny because tolkien
himself spent a long time i think
trying to get the lord of the rings
going um even the the hobbit i think it
took a long time
there's actually there's a really good
book by tom shippy called tolkien author
of the century
and tolkien um i think just um
you know he was just he was like grading
papers or something and just
scratched down the line uh in a hole in
the ground they're live to hobbit
without really knowing anything else
about the story and then it took
i think years before he actually turned
that into a book uh it was sort of
stories that he told to his children
initially
um but i think the key thing with an
epic fantasy like that is you need to
start small so
um you know the fellowship of the ring
starts
you know with very ordinary you know
with characters that are very much like
the reader would be
the hobbits are basically sort of
english people um
and they're off in the middle of nowhere
and so we're introduced to
you know the world slowly um and this is
a mistake you see or at least you know
something that i don't think works as
well for example in the star wars
prequels
where you're immediately thrown into the
you know the politics of the galactic
civilization and all that and everything
right it
it works it just just the the formula of
an epic fantasy tends to work better
when you have somebody who's like
completely in the outskirts i mean the
original star wars movie follows the
same four
formula right you have someone who's on
the outskirts and
they they slowly get introduced they
sort of get pulled into the center
throughout one or more books and so that
would be
my my main thing is start with a
character who's relatable and who exists
on the periphery of this world
and don't try to get too crazy with the
politics or the economics or
or you know the different cultures right
off the bat you need to start small and
kind of work your way in
very good thanks brian and thanks for
the question and thanks for the super
chat
i appreciate that uh okay so
next up i wanna i'm gonna scroll through
on my screen share you won't see this
dave but i'm gonna put it up on the
screen
and that will be a list of your past
guests
including many people as i said we have
guests uh that
we've had in common like uh bro katie
mack
and brian greene and and other people in
the science field
but also people in politics and culture
as a whole and you've had people on you
know that have
some degree of controversy as they might
say over there across the pond
uh gary kasparov is somewhat
controversial
richard clarke who i want to get into uh
in a little bit
and then you know people that are very
interested in
in either hard science or hard science
fiction you've had on ross douthat
scott adams um you and i talked about
this a little bit offline but
but my question i have you know in some
sense is uh how much oversight or how
much control
does wired exert you know if you're
gonna have on
uh noam chomsky or like you know i i've
had him on
or you're gonna have on you know ben
shapiro who i've also had on you know do
they
offer any kind of editorial guidance or
are you mostly free to select and choose
based on your
um your your kind of considerable
reputation that that you've developed
uh i've been free to interview who i
want um you know um
you know since we just started the
podcast on our own we never really had a
lot of editorial oversight
so um my editor wired has mostly just
sort of
helped out on the production side just
getting the posts up and
you know dealing with technical issues
and stuff like that
um to this you so so as i told you in
in our interview to this point i've
never um they never said you can't
interview
i never checked you know who who i um
before i've interviewed anyone and
they've never said you shouldn't have
interviewed that person or you can't
interview so and so
um i do kind of feel like the the thing
is that you know i'm just a freelancer
so i'm not
honestly that aware of what
conversations might be happening within
the organization
but um and i do feel certainly i'm kind
of aware just because of the
just the culture that we're in that
people are becoming more and more and
more
constrained uh about what they can talk
about and that's why
we've seen so many sort of top-ranked
journalists leaving
media organizations because they feel
like they just can't do the kind of
journalism they want to do
um you know unless they're independent
um
so it's but but for me it's been sort of
more like background noise like nothing
is actually impinged on my ability to
interview who i want
so far is there anyone that you would
not interview i mean other people
in popular culture or you know that
aren't obviously
odious uh racist you know misogynist or
whatever are there are there topics that
you wouldn't touch or
are let me ask you this first dave
do you feel kind of a pressure to
balance you know
for every nine episodes of you know
science fiction or fantasy
one episode of non-science fiction or
fantasy or
or vice versa rather if you do one
episode that's political with
with uh scott adams or something i'm not
saying i disagree or agree with him but
just making an example do you feel like
there's a there should be a
fair and balanced approach to things as
they say
well the thing is that you know like
i've i've been doing this for 10 years
and i've interviewed probably something
like 450 people
well no that's 400 and something people
who are on the left or far left
and like five to eight maybe who are
conservative or libertarian and the
complaints i get are all like you're
interviewing too many people who are
conservative or a libertarian
um which seems kind of ridiculous to me
yeah um
so i'm not too moved by the
idea that i'm i'm you know too slanted
toward
conservatives like that just seems
absurd to me um
in terms of like who i would like i told
you i'd have on pretty much anyone that
i thought would be
like whoever's the most interesting
person to me to talk to
that week is pretty much who i line up
an interview with
um and uh you know like i said i've
interviewed a lot of controversial
people but i don't usually talk to them
about
what's made them controversial because
it's usually been covered to death
and it's not really that interesting to
me right um
but if i'm talking to someone
controversial it's usually like do you
like science fiction what kind of
science fiction books do you read
because that's more interesting to me
it's like you know here's this person
who
everyone kind of knows and no one's ever
asked them like
what kind of science fiction do you read
so that's that's kind of that's much
more interesting to me than some
hot button issue which i'm not an expert
on i you know i don't have much to
contribute probably
um i mean a lot of the people i
interview i don't honestly know that
much
about them you know like it'll just be
some some person who i know
is um you know who seems interesting
who's uh who i know is newsworthy
but i i haven't gone and looked at
everything they have ever tweeted or
you know i and i don't care honestly um
so
uh um so yeah i just
i i want to make the kind of show that i
would want to listen to and so i mean
when i was talking to you right you said
like oh i've interviewed ben shapiro
um and i'm like oh that would be
interesting i'm not at all
an admirer of ben shapiro i read one of
his books it was called bullies
um and i wasn't that impressed by it but
he seems like a really interesting
like if i like when i looked at your
podcast it's like oh there's an
interview with ben shapiro
i'm kind of curious to listen to that so
i want to
you know create the kind of content that
i personally would be interested
as a listener if i came across it um
but you know something like is there but
there's there's basically no one i
wouldn't
talk to probably um except in sort of
pragmatic terms i mean like like
philosophically there's there's not
really anyone
right i mean realistically like i have
to think like how much crap am i gonna
get for this how much crap is wired
gonna get for this
um and is it worth it like like how just
how much emotional energy do i have
to deal with the potential blowback like
right now
um but um philosophically i would want
to hear from anyone who's
smart and interesting yeah um and one
thing i think about all i mean honestly
i honestly think about this a lot is
like if uh
hannibal lecter had written game of
thrones would i interview hannibal
lecter about game of thrones
and i'm kind of like i kind of would i
mean you know because it's it's such a
great book
and obviously i think hannibal lecter
should be in prison for the hannibal
elector stuff
but um you know those are sort of
separate things
in my mind and there was a lionel
shriver
quote that really stuck with me where
she said something like
i don't understand why um
when someone has done things that are
bad we have to destroy everything that
they've ever done that was good
as part of that yeah and i
that's i totally agree with that i mean
if someone's done things that are bad
they should be punished for the bad
things and if they've done things that
are good they should be appreciated for
the good things
in reasonable proportion um and we
shouldn't let the
you know like the things we don't like
about people erase everything good that
they've ever done
yeah well yeah actually let me get your
opinion and also ask my audience as well
reminder we're talking to
david barr curtly the uh founder
and director producer recorder all those
good things
of the uh of wired magazines geek's
guide to the galaxy
and i want to encourage you to subscribe
to him he does have a youtube channel
i will put it in the show notes but he
has primarily a
phenomenal uh podcast audio podcast
that you can find under the same name
geeks got to the galaxy i've got the
logo up there
you can find it please leave a review
there uh please do the same for the into
the impossible podcast on
itunes as well or wherever you get are
there other places that you can review
podcasting
or is itunes i mean itunes is definitely
the big one um
stitcher was kind of up there for a
while i don't know
how active people are reviewing stuff on
stitcher but
um yeah definitely itunes would be the
one to go to so asking my audience right
now
uh what do you think about me and maybe
dave maybe you're already doing this
lawrence krauss
has a book coming out lawrence krauss is
a
cosmologist he was a former professor he
was
a formerly a professor at my alma mater
which is case western reserve university
he came in right when i left and maybe
that was a good uh fortunate timing for
me but
uh he was later at arizona state
university
and there was a uh not a small bit of
controversy
over my friend or former friend
lawrence krauss and that had to do with
allegations made
and you can just look up those
allegations made of a of a metoo type
type of affair and i've actually met him
in person i actually think he's very
bright
but would you have uh i don't know if
you're familiar with him
yourself dave uh but would you ha he has
a new book coming out about the physics
of climate change
and i'm just looking up his wikipedia
page so this is not hearsay
or liable or anything i'll show it on
the screen just so that it's not me
making this up
uh he is controversial for the following
uh
i don't want to say affair sorry guys um
he founded
asu's origins project and uh upon
investigating
allegations about sexual misconduct by
krauss asu determined that he had
violated university policy
and removed him from the origin project
directorship in july
2018 he continued as a professor until
retiring in 2019
and now he hosts a podcast himself so
besides us having to compete with
uh with lawrence uh dave would you
would you have him on the show is that
somebody that you'd uh feel comfortable
hosting on your podcast yeah i mean we
talked about this last time but yeah i
would
i would you know i would interview like
i said pretty much anyone who
if they seems like the most interesting
person that i
wanted to talk to that week i have
interviewed lawrence krauss
um i mean a big part of the reason that
i
um started podcasting was because i was
so inspired by
kind of the new atheist group that was
big in pot you know sort of podcasting
when i
started and you know i'm a lifelong
atheist and i really felt that
um the atheists were kind of all in the
closet and having people like richard
dawkins and sam harris and
christopher hitchens come out um you
know was was really
important to me um really made me you
know
sort of not afraid or you know not feel
like it was something that i had to not
talk about so i mean i'm a great admirer
of all of those people
um i you know i don't know
exactly what this the details are
with um the situation with lawrence
krauss
um i don't i mean some of these have
really
thought some of these sorts of things i
i don't really trust the
investigations that have been done i
don't know if you're familiar with the
case of stephen galloway
at the university of british columbia no
but he he was forced out
um facing very very serious accusations
which seemed to have just not been true
at all
um and i i just don't you know
i just feel like you can't necessarily
take
i don't i feel like a lot of
organizations um they do what's best for
their public relations
and so i don't necessarily uh
know what the what the truth is my
understanding is that lawrence krauss
has denied the accusation
i don't i don't know a lot of the
details but um i mean
yeah some of them he had uh in
particular but i'm just reading the
i can put it up on the screen here um
let's see let me share my screen here
yeah so
university finds promenas visas grabbed
a woman's breasts
and there was actually a fair bit it
wasn't just one in
uh one event where this took place
um in other words and you know he
definitely
had denied it but there were multiple
articles uh
and then he did offer extensive
rebuttals as you said but there's
there was a lot and obviously the
university took these uh took these
steps doesn't mean that it's you know
proven just because of that but i do
believe that
there you know in this in this case
there was a fair amount of
i don't know about the the galloway case
that you mentioned um
and i and he denied uh you know that
that he's done this and
and so forth um but you know he's just
an example
of somebody obviously you know you could
find examples on each side yeah go ahead
well let me just say i mean i i think
that you know the the
regardless of of what the situation was
my feeling in these situations is that
the punishment needs to be proportional
to
the wrong and that once the punishment
has kind of matched you know what the
person has done wrong
it's time to kind of let them
re-enter a society and i feel like when
you've been
you know forced out of your job and you
know it's been a whole public thing
and um you're just trying to it's you
know i think several years have passed
and you're just trying to promote your
new book
uh i think we have to give people
chances to
continue being part of the community
because i think that the alternative is
it's just not a not a society that i
want to live in
a a really punitive society and i'll
also say i mean this is um
one thing i learned when i was studying
criminal justice in college
is that what helps somebody
um uh rehabilitate
when they've been punished for a crime
is if they feel that the punishment
has been tough but fair and if people
feel that the punishment has been cruel
and gratuitous even if they know that
even if they did commit a crime
but if they feel that they were punished
unju you know excessively
that just makes them much more likely to
be to engage in recidivism much more
likely to double down on their behavior
much more likely to fight against the
system that they feel punish them
unfairly
so i just think all around we want
punishments to be proportional
and based on good evidence and
um and to
you know to not uh hold things up
holding over hold things over people's
head
for year after year after year um and
that's that's just i don't know that's
just kind of how i see it
that's a very uh very tolerant christian
message that you're promoting i wonder
if lawrence would accept that uh
shot at redemption and forbearance that
you're offering
i salute that sentiment i dislike and i
talked to nom chomsky about this
the so-called cancel culture and you
know you can't have anyone more
diametrically opposed to
some of the political opinions that i
have at least than nom chomsky but
uh i find that i can isolate and
compartmentalize
you know particular feelings i have
about his controversial statements that
he's made
uh from the things i really want to talk
to him about which is science even
science fiction uh and so forth so
um i i i actually can i jump in there
yeah brian because
um you know like i said i was i was a
great admirer of the
the new atheist because i felt like they
were making it okay for atheists to come
out of the closet
and just be honest about how we feel
and um you know maybe i don't know four
or five years ago i would have described
myself
as a you know like a bernie sanders
style
social you know democratic socialist you
know very very left-wing
and just watching kind of how mean
people on the left have been
has really made me kind of disillusioned
with
with the left and so i'm still i would
still consider myself pretty far left
but i'm uh
i'm definitely just sort of like
heartbroken over a lot of things
yeah and yeah i mean when i'm uh as
i you know you know i'm jewish and from
new york and when we're born you know
democratic
socialist is stamped on our pat on our
birth certificates pretty much
uh but you know i resonate with that uh
with what you're saying
and uh and i don't know if you listen to
the long podcast i had with eric
weinstein yesterday but
you know he's basically saying like um
he's daring and he's as hard left as you
can get you know going
back to like you know protesting against
reagan and extremely
but he finds he's not getting invited to
speak anymore to people on the left
and so he goes on the right and that
just feeds this
you know glenn beck he was on glenn beck
this past weekend and making very very
clear-cut very very non-controversial
used to be non-controversial statements
but admitting that his appearing on the
you know it's kind of this
infinite cycle of iteration where you go
on
the the right wing shows because they're
the only ones that will admit you and no
matter how much you say that's left
leaning
they will then use that as a cudgel to
bash you not to come on anything in
polite leftist society so i agree with
you i agree with eric um
it's it's disappointing because i think
you know the healthiest thing
and for the first time in human history
we have we have a scenario where someone
who built their livelihood on books you
know namely jeff bezos
running a newspaper that for the first
time in history the newspaper has no
profit motive i mean they'll survive and
do they could run nothing but you know
attack ads and and cancel culture and do
whatever they want to do and i'm not
criticizing them i've got friends that
actually work there uh very close
friends but the point is
you know it's a very different time in
history and i think there is a strong
imbalance and what i worry about
is that just as the left you know kind
of uh
viewed trump as this as this antichrist
and whatever and you could say a lot of
bad things about him and i'll i'm fine
you know discussing that but um if they
go too far
i think it could could come back to
haunt even the left i don't know how you
feel about that
yeah well absol i mean i think that you
know nietzsche has this line that
um those who fight monsters should be
careful that they don't
in the process become monsters and i
feel like i you know trump is like the
last person i would ever want to be
president i don't
think there's almost anything good to
say about him and i feel like the left
in the time in in his thankfully
shorter time in office um you know sort
of became a mirror image of a lot of
the things i i don't like about it but
where i was going um
when you mentioned you know the the
christian charity idea
you know when i was growing up i really
saw that the people that i i sort of
disliked the most in america
were the sort of christian
fundamentalists who wanted to
ban dungeons and dragons right i mean
that was like the big
like thing that just pissed me off as a
teenager right and um
and so i always thought that those
people would be the people that i i
disliked the most you know throughout my
life but i i definitely realized that
i don't like you know
uh what sort of tribalism or hypocrisy
or yeah group thing you know or or any
of these things when they come from the
left any more than as a kid i liked that
when it was coming from the right
yeah i worry about that pendulum effect
this is bound to happen you know i
always say to my friends who
always advocate for maximum tax brackets
like do you not think they'll ever be a
republican president who will then take
all the tax money that you've raised and
build you know six trillion more nuclear
weapons and and
let's get into that because you had on
richard clark who had uh love an
introduction to at some point
uh he's probably the name you know
related to our namesake arthur c clarke
so that'll make the introduction
very easy but he you know he's obviously
very strongly
anti he's anti george bush it's also
funny by the way to see
you know people that that thought of
george bush in exactly the same way i
mean i have a poster because i won a
presidential award from george bush
while he was in office i met him i went
to the white house i shook his hand i
hung out in the oval office
with him and uh and i remember my
colleagues in academia say like how
could you be with that
satanist like the awful human being who
killed millions and trillions of people
and then like uh eight years later nine
years later
he's such a generous soul and why can't
more why can't donald trump be more like
george bush and
i'm just waiting i don't know about you
in the in the future what what they'll
say about
that donald trump he was just you know
he was rough around the edges but you
know the kai
was just so much better than insert you
know the insert current republican there
but i i
i do feel like we've gotten away from
stuff but one thing that that
your interview with richard clark you
know which is from a couple of years ago
have you had him back on since he wrote
the cassandra book the cassandra book is
uh using learning from cassandra's to
avoid catastrophe
did you have them on after that
interview
no no i've i've i haven't repeated any
future interview with any of the guests
and that's just because i want to reach
the widest variety of all right so i
blew it
i blew it i had my chance i blew it i'll
never come back on geek's guide
i'll never be featured no matter how
many sometimes people come back
as panelists so but it would be and i
might start repeating future interviews
i mean after 10 years
you know i figure maybe it's time but uh
but so far i haven't interviewed anybody
more than once i don't think
yeah you've just had some i mean some of
them would be great to have like ursula
le guin uh unfortunately you won't be
able to do that
interview anymore um but let's talk
about the interview you did do with with
uh richard clark
uh about which which actually devolved
into a very nice conversation about
science fiction and
uh how many guests would you have come
on that
are not interested in science fiction or
fantasy i mean do you talk to people and
just never bring it up or is it always
a consistent kind of part of your brand
uh no there have definitely been
interviews i have done that haven't
touched on science fiction i mean i try
i'm always more interested in people who
are science fiction fans you know that's
why my ideal guest is some
you know leading intellectual who has a
secret passion for science fiction that
they've never talked
about before so i i always try to ask
everybody
are you hey how into science fiction are
you and sometimes like i'm not really
into science fiction i'm like okay well
moving on um but um
yeah in terms of like who you know it's
hard to say like who
is a good geeks guide to the galaxy gas
like the way i try to think a bit
think of it is this is a person who
would be interesting to a science
fiction fan
even if they're not necessarily in the
science fiction world or whatever
um so to give you an example like um you
know adam carolla had a book that came
out
within the past year and i think that uh
it would be very interesting to talk to
him but he's just like not geeky enough
somehow like he's not on brand for
geek's guide to the galaxy
and i mean there was somebody there was
a guy a former fbi agent
named clinton watts that i interviewed
he wrote a book about sort of
you know negotiation trolls and things
online
which i figured was sort of like techy
enough for a geek's guide to the galaxy
but that would be sort of like
that was kind of on the edge of what i
would consider like you know
science fiction geeky enough for our
podcast um
if that gives you an idea definitely
yeah
so um when you talk to clark yeah it
came out that he was
um you know he he was interesting
because he was talking a lot about the
you know nuclear proliferation and then
how he used science fiction to
communicate
uh to you know generals and politicians
uh imminent threats to national security
so first maybe you could describe a
little bit about
you know who he is but but i found it
very interesting because i i view
science fiction as a pre-gaming
of the future you know kind of shows us
what the future could be like
and i had this conversation with dave
rubin on the podcast and it's like
you know literally we're seeing people
burning books now and you know obviously
like we talked about in fahrenheit 451
and how science fiction can avert almost
the dystopian aspects of
actual real life you know truth being
stranger than fiction so
i found that very interesting that he
was talking with generals and even heads
of state
about science fiction scenarios that
then could be used to break down some of
the tech
and and so forth that was above their uh
above their intellectual grasp
if you can imagine that there are
politicians who can't understand laws of
physics but
what stood out to you about that uh kind
of conversation and the use of science
fiction different than
than we've discussed so far yeah well so
i mean that was
several years ago so i don't know if i
remember exactly what we talked about i
mean he was a very high-ranking
um intelligence official yeah and he's
sort of famous for
um testifying before congress that he
thinks that the bush administration
could have prevented 911
if they had made more of an effort to
find out what people on the ground you
know fbi agents and such on the ground
were were saying and trying to
communicate up the chain
uh i'm sort of that's above my pay grade
in terms of evaluating
that but i i thought it was you would be
an interesting person to talk to
um and his book was about yeah it was
about different people
who have correctly predicted big
disasters um or
i guess the first half is about people
who correctly predicted
uh disastrous in the past and in the
second half was about people who are
currently predicting disasters in the
future and how much
attention should we be paying to them um
i honestly since you you listened to it
more recently than i have you i might
need you to
point me to some specific things from it
one thing that spoke to me is he was
just like
um yeah you know this he couldn't be
hilariously more wrong but he's like
cyber
security and you know coordinated
internet attack and
that could never happen you know just
like last week you know this
uh russian cyber attack um but the
the other thing that he kind of
mentioned is that yeah because
people it's it might be more accessible
fiction
movies and so forth are more accessible
than are some differential equations to
describe the trajectory of an icbm you
know
or what would happen if an asteroid hit
the earth you know and like oh okay you
remember that movie with bruce willis
okay fine yeah i can do that
and then and then tapering down from
that saying well that's not super
realistic you probably wouldn't want to
blow up the asteroid
creating you know 10 to the six more
asteroids but nevertheless you know you
should something it's something you
should think about you know
making it more vivid i i found that very
interesting
and uh actually could i could i jump in
on the asteroid thing because there's
the funniest story i heard once where um
he was out of sight i think it was at a
science fiction convention i just heard
about this sort of third hand
but an author was working on a book
about a um
an asteroid heading for earth and the
scientists were trying to use mirrors to
to melt the asteroid
and um and somebody said well couldn't
they just melt
one side of it and then convection or
something would push it off course
you know wouldn't that work and the
writer says god i hope not
you know because that would ruin the
whole book
the whole i think in the end he ended up
making the asteroid ten times bigger
than previously than it was previously
in order to uh
uh you know fix that to fix that problem
uh i have a question
a very detailed question from carlos
casaya uh who asked
david considering you studied political
philosophy
and love and write amazing science
fiction
what relation do you find between sci-fi
and philosophy
and then in parentheses he says ethics
philosophy of mind
and metaphysics so what do you love and
and uh and
how do you relate between sci-fi and
philosophy
specifically yeah well i mean the reason
i studied
political science in college was
explicitly because i wanted to write
science fiction that dealt with politics
i mean i had
you know really liked books like
starship troopers by robert heinlein
that that goes a lot into
you know political ideas um i mean
probably i wouldn't agree with them
now if i read it but it's just the just
the idea of having this like
professor talk about the student talk
with the students about what's right and
wrong and what their duties are as
citizens and stuff like that i just love
that stuff and i wanted to be able to
write
you know um fbi agents and
um you know soldiers and uh presidents
and
kind of characters with some you know
some level of uh
uh of knowledge um and philosophy is
always
yeah and and this and the political
science i studied was was more
more on the philosophical side you know
so constitutional law
and um political philosophy um you know
so like
you know why is free speech so important
you know
um things like that um and my favorite
you know like
like i said my favorite um fantasy
series growing up is the chronicles of
amber
by roger zelazny uh who was just an
incredibly
erudite um guy you know he just knew so
much about so many different subjects
and the um and the serious deals you
know the whole
point of the series is sort of like
what's real and what's not and there's
all these
every book you find out that there's
actually some deeper layer of reality
that you didn't know about before and
and the characters constantly have their
um their ideas about what's real and
what isn't
uh upended and so um so all those things
yeah were hugely influential to me in
terms of
and and the thing i like one of the main
things i like about science fiction
is because i like thought experiments
and a science fiction story a good one
is
is often a thought experiment with
characters that you really care about
and um which to me is sort of the best
of of both worlds
very good um okay we're gonna start uh
winding down
at some point so i ask you guys to
chime in with your comments and
questions for dave in the remaining few
minutes that
we have on this live stream broadcast of
the into the impossible podcast
with our uh friend and fellow podcaster
extraordinaire david currently the
uh the the proprietor of the geeks guide
to the galaxy
all things geeky got so excited when i
went on his show
and i know that you'll love and uh
cherish his
episodes which have a lot in common in
some ways but are completely different
in other ways from
the kinds of fair that i produce on
the into the impossible podcast um
we're seeing you know some some
questions more about the
uh kind of riffing off of the asteroid
theme
and we were just talking about as well
but um okay so martin is asking
for uh some awesome predictions now i
don't know if that means
predictions about you know politics or
whatever let's stick to sci-fi
fantasy what are you looking forward to
in 21 when it comes to movies or because
you do a lot of film
reviews as well what are you looking
forward to this year i know i'm looking
forward to one
fantasy movie called top gun two
maverick one of my sons and i
are maverick uh freaks and geeks uh what
are you looking forward to
in the film or a book genre in this year
coming up
um well i mean
you know it's actually been really
challenging this past year doing a
a podcast that relies so heavily on film
and tv reviews because
so many uh film and tv you know
films and tv shows have been pushed back
or whatever
um so i've sort of had to scramble a
little bit to because you know because
there's always
there's a there's an infinite number of
books that i want to read but
like i said since i'm not that fast of a
reader i kind of have to balance you
know like oh if i
you know this book is a little bit long
but if i just do a movie this
week then that'll give me more time to
read this book for next week
and so um yeah so the fact that there
have been so few new
hope uh new high-profile movies coming
out has really been a challenge um
i mean the reason i laugh is because you
know i'm kind of like well i'm waiting
for the
the next george rr martin book to come
out and like fingers crossed 2021
is going yeah you did like a linear
regression to calculate when that would
come out that was pretty good
yeah actually you know i think you might
you you said you listened to my
interview with ross stout that we were
talking about that and that
where yes somebody had plotted it wasn't
me but somebody plotted it as a curve
you know based on when the books had
come out predicting that the the next
book would come out in 2020
that's pretty good martin martin i hope
you liked that
and then you know that didn't you know
and at the time i forget
now i can't even remember the years
anymore but at the time that was i think
six or seven years in the future and it
just seemed absurd like obviously it'll
be before 2020
and now it's 2021 and i i think it's
gonna i
my understanding is that there's a good
chance it's going to come out this year
what about
zach chapman's asking about dune yeah
yeah well
um i'm definitely looking forward to
that i don't know if you followed
there's been this whole controversy
with the studio um taking all these
movies and
you know making them part of i forget if
it's hbo max or something you know
and the filmmakers being unhappy with
that yeah i've heard um
but i i don't know sir and you know um
the director of dune
um danita vote danny villeneuve he said
that he
thought that this decision uh to release
the movie
uh online rather than in theaters was
probably gonna mean that there would be
no more
movies in the dune series um so he was
on
my understanding is he was pretty
unhappy about that wow but
um i'm desperate to see it um
you know i actually just read dune this
year for the first time uh
we did an episode about it i had tried
to read it a few times as a kid and and
never got into it and so
since the movie was coming out i was
like all right this is my year
i'm gonna read it uh and i did and i
read the whole thing out loud which
if you listen to that panel i don't know
if you can tell i'm i'm losing my voice
yeah you're a little hoarse yeah
it's a 650 page book or something and i
read the whole thing out loud and it
just like
finished off my voice but yeah uh
so and then the last question on this
theme would be what was last year's best
science fiction
movie or book in 2020
uh boy i'd have to i read a lot of stuff
i mean the um the movies that i would
encourage everyone to check out
from i think it was last year would be
these independent movies
prospect and the endless which uh
you know have pretty low budgets but
just do amazing things
um within the the budgetary constraints
um i don't i'd have to look at the
list to see what was my favorite book i
read last year yeah
um yeah i i don't know off the top of my
head i'm not sure
okay all right well we're going to wind
down uh before i ask the three questions
the thrilling three questions that is my
trademark uh content on the into the
impossible podcast
you said something that was really uh
kind of fascinating to me
in your interview with michael shermer
can you comment on that no i'm just
kidding
i don't actually imagine if you remember
oh yeah i know exactly but you said the
following i'm quoting you
uh on michael schumer episode most moral
moral failures are failures of
imagination
and this is the into the impossible
podcast was a production
of the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination what did you mean
dave when you said that most moral
failures are failures of imagination
is very provocative in a good way yeah
well i mean as
i as i went on to say to to michael i
mean
um you know and i think i've said this
in a couple interviews but
you know usually when you're doing
something bad
it's because you are not imagining
vividly enough either the consequences
or what somebody else
is experiencing as a result of your
actions
um and so there's been some research i
think um
showing that people who read fiction and
put their self
put themselves in the heads of
characters develop more empathy
for that experience and so i think that
imagining that you are as many different
kinds of people as you can
is is almost certainly valuable for
developing your empathy
um and um and i would just extend that
more broadly to i mean one of the things
i
i always say is that's valuable about
science fiction is that it makes you
imagine people in the future and what
their lives will be like and that so
many of the choices that we make today
are kind of short-sighted and are kind
of
going to make the future much worse for
sort of a short-term
can be short-term convenience or some
short-term benefit or something
and that if you're constantly thinking
if you're constantly imagining oh people
in 500 years people in a thousand years
are going to have lives like this
i think that helps you to make more
um you know more conscientious decisions
today
um yeah
all right i'm gonna i deserve some
applause
people out there have always complained
that i used to too high a volume
on my sound effects so to them i say
we'll do that it'll be the dji air horn
so if you guys don't like it turn off
but i'm gonna get all
my money's worth and more uh dave thank
you so much now
it is time for the patented into the
impossible
thrilling three questions i'm gonna
queue them up
while i do so listen to some relaxing
music by friend of the show
miguel tully of the yeti tears instagram
channel
and uh also on twitter and
on youtube as well okay here comes
the into the impossible final three
questions for none other than
mr david barr currently proprietor of
the geeks guy to the galaxy
here we go so number one there's a
concept
in many religions but i know it from my
tradition of judaism
of what's called the ethical will and
the ethical will
is the wisdom it is the
sort of not not necessarily knowledge
but wisdom that you want to pass on
to future generations and it doesn't you
know have to be
uh going to be something that's
immediately useful to technology
or so forth but uh i want to ask you
what you most want to pass on to future
generations that you've accumulated
maybe through the podcast maybe through
your intellectual curiosity
what do you want to pass on to denizens
of the future
that will be willing to benefit from
uh from your ethical wisdom well i mean
i can sort of
tell you what sticks you know from
studying moral philosophy in college the
the two things that have really stuck
with me
are um um you know
there's a book uh called on liberty by
john stewart mill
where he talks about what's so important
about free speech
and i i honestly feel that if you
went to call i would rather have people
go to college and learn nothing
else but that free speech isn't why free
speech is so important
i'd rather that than learn everything
else but not
appreciate that free speech is important
i i think it's that important i don't
think you can have any sort of society
without free speech
um and the other idea that really stuck
with me
is um you know emanuel khan basically
said that
um in in
evaluating whether an action is ethical
or not
you should think well what would society
be like if everybody were to do this
yeah the categorical imperative right
yeah yeah and so i think that that's
i i think so many um like
you know yeah so many judgments people
have are are
short-sighted or parochial or something
where they're they're only thinking
about the short-term
consequences where they're like yeah and
it goes to free speech too it's like i'm
going to silence this person
and then the world will be better
because they're saying things that are
bad and it's like well no you have to
think like
if you silence this person how are they
going to respond how are people who like
them going to respond you know and so on
and so on and so on
and so i think that and so many people
you know i i i have this issue with a
lot of my friends who i love but
um you know they'll say like well this
person's bad they should just be
blacklisted out of the industry or you
know silenced et cetera
and i'm kind of like well what about you
know if we're if we're in the business
of blacklisting people what about this
person who you like and they're like oh
no no they would be totally wrong if
that work person would were to be
blacklisted
and you're like well what makes them
better than that person and they're like
well that person's good and that
person's bad
so of course we should you know endorse
the people who are good and blacklist
the people who are bad and it's like
well
you have to like you have to like get
outside yourself and look at this
from other perspectives and just like
see like the real question here is like
do you want to live in a society where
people are being blacklisted or do you
not want to live in a society
where people are being blacklisted and
any society
where that isn't you know isn't cruel
is is preferable to any society that is
cruel
even if it's mostly redounding to the
benefit of
your side um so so those are the two
things in college that i learned and
then
you know one of my big influences
growing up was the ultimate series of
computer role-playing games designed by
richard garriott
and in ultima 4 he introduced this idea
that there are these eight virtues
and how you win the game is by proving
yourself in each of the eight virtues
right
and the eight virtues he needed eight
for the game because three wasn't enough
um but the but the eight are sort of uh
combinations and permutations of the
three
and the three are truth love and courage
and i think that you
you know if you have to pick three
things that you're going to
live your life by i think you could do a
lot worse than truth love and courage
and one of the things that i've been
kind of on about on the show recently
is that um you know in the game you have
to pick
you know how you create your characters
or presents you with these questions and
it says like
you know do you think that you know
effectively do you think that honor is
more important than
uh sacrifice or whatever and so one of
the choices you might have to make is do
you think that truth is more important
than justice
and the more that i've thought about
this and they're both like good right
both truth and justice are important
yeah
but the more i thought about this i
think that if there's ever any um
conflict between truth and justice
you have to go with truth the truth is
the paramount
uh principle and once you get a once
once you've decided that it doesn't
matter what's true
for whatever reason even if you have
what in your mind a good reason
i think that's you know the the road to
hell is paved with
any time you get away from what you know
what you know is true right
you know that's very uh very beautifully
put and
uh i love the philosophical uh aspect of
it
you might like this i haven't tried this
i'm gonna be
helping some friends of mine out with a
movie they're making about
theories of everything and and uh
science and religion and things that
interest me uh
as well but uh i was talking to them
today and they were asking about the
multiverse and
and that features very prominently in a
lot of science fiction and
and so forth uh and obviously it's a big
part of science non-fiction and science
uh fact right now in my field of
cosmology
and there's this concept of something
called the landscape which is
uh which is an artifact or a consequence
of string theory
wherein there might be something like 10
to the power 500
different vacua of string theory that
could exist and
and might have to exist in a certain
sense in multiple dimensions maybe 10
dimensions of space-time
and that these 10 to the 500th power
universes would all have their differing
laws of physics not only
physical constants it might be that
there are different laws of
uh there might be different laws of of
nature
and so i started to think well wouldn't
it be interesting why stop there
you know whether if if they're not
stopping at different laws at different
physical constants in other words the
speed of light guaranteed would be
different
in universe you know number 7522
over there in the towards the
constellation aries or something
but uh but certainly the laws of physics
would why not the laws of logic
in other words why not the laws of time
and you know why isn't modis
tollens it could be different it could
be you know affirming the the
the consequent or something you know so
it would be interesting to
to flesh out a science fiction
multiverse like that where
not only the laws of physics which stem
after all from
certain applied aspects of mathematics
which in turn
flow from set theory and laws of
mathematics and
philosophy at their core the ground of
the tree of knowledge is planted in
philosophy
uh so i think it's very beautiful what
you said uh let me turn to the next
question which uh
directly actually can i could i jump in
yeah of course i mean the the um series
that i mentioned earlier the chronicles
of amber by roger zelazny
you know i i i don't know if i mentioned
or not but um there's parallel worlds
there's an infinite number of parallel
worlds
and the laws of physics differ from
world to worlds that's sort of one of
the main features
of the series and so in book six um
there's a scene i've always loved where
the character who's a computer he's a
computer scientist living in san
francisco but he's you know he's from
this magical world
originally but he has this plan on his
drawing board
and one of his friends says like well
what is this uh what is this thing
you're drawing and he's like oh it's
just it's a theoretical exercise it
could never be built
um because because of the laws of
physics but it turns out that because he
can go to any worlds that he can imagine
he's found a world where the laws of
physics are such that he can build this
thing which is this you know super
powered ai kind of machine
and i've just always loved that idea
that you know
that you could that the law of physics
could be different and maybe you could
build things
there that you can't build here very
good okay
next question involves uh the namesake
of this
fine institution the arthur c clarke
center for
human imagination and that involves the
so-called monolith that is present in
the beginning
of 2001 a space odyssey where these uh
primates on the plains of africa
discover this monolith and kind of hit
it with their bones and
do all sorts of silly stuff to it they
don't really know how to handle it
but it's thought that it might be later
on in the novel series that it sort of
represents a time capsule or some
uh encoded wisdom or knowledge rather
that humans are meant to
encounter if and only if they're able to
decipher it so
it later makes an appearance on the moon
in space etc
but i want to ask you if you had access
to a monolith as did carl sagan's widow
ann drurian who was a guest on the show
over the summer
so carl sagan author of contact and his
co-author was his
wife uh andrewian so they made
a record an actual disc golden disk on
the voyager 1 spacecraft launched into
space that included
world music it included sounds of birds
and human beings it also included her
brain waves
i want to ask you and she was told that
would last for perhaps a billion to 4
billion years
i want to ask you dave if you had access
to a time capsule guaranteed to last for
one billion years like a monolith
in 2001 what would you put on it in it
what would it represent uh as far as
you're concerned
uh i mean this may be on
uh i'm tempted to say i would include
every episode of geek's guide to the
galaxy
because i mean like i don't know
i don't know if that sounds uh
ridiculous but i mean like i i always
like that's why i
make the like every every episode i
don't know if people have noticed but
when there's something that requires
some explanation you know
that's topical you know where it's like
okay if you're listening to this in the
future
you need to understand this or else what
this person just said makes no sense
i'm always thinking like wait people in
a million years might be listening to
this i hope they are
and they're going to want they're going
to need some of these things explained
for them
and um you know i don't know
uh i i i think that to be a
to be a writer to be a podcaster to be a
creative person
you have to maybe have some delusional
um
you know idea of your own importance or
else why would you
bother putting all this work into it
when you could be so many things would
be more easy
easier and more uh remunerative and so
on
um and so uh yeah i mean
i mean obviously there's lots of stuff i
would put in there but i
i do think of geek's guide to the galaxy
as i try really really hard to make it
something that
is going to be worth listening to far
far into the future
yeah i definitely uh find resonance in
what you say not only because i do the
podcast but
because i i wanted to influence people
to the good it's part of the reason i
wrote my book
uh because i had a chance to maybe
influence a younger version of myself
and i in fact have i've had guests on
you know
um here i am you know a a jewish person
from new york and
and now i've got a friend who's a
practicing devout muslim
in egypt and she and i she came on my
show i came on her show
and it's like those kinds of things
wouldn't happen if we didn't have
podcasts and we weren't able to broach
these vast distances
and uh and communicate with this magical
device
that really leads me perfectly into my
next question which is
uh relevant to pertinent to arthur c
clarke's
first law or some say it's his third law
i'm going to use it as his first law
which is that any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic that was
his first law
my taxonomy his second law was
for every expert there's an equal and
opposite
expert i like to pull that out on my
friends in the faculty club
and then finally he said the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
that's the origin of this podcast name
i want to ask you going backwards in
time for a change
what advice would you give to your
former self what
would you most be intrigued to learn
perhaps or perhaps give you the courage
to go
beyond your comfort zone a little bit
into the impossible
yeah well i think really just doing a
podcast at all is something that i would
have thought
as a kid was impossible i mean just
obviously because there were no podcasts
so
it's impossible on that level but also i
mean i like i said at the beginning i
don't
like really being looked at or like i'm
not doing this because i personally
like attention i don't um and like as a
kid i i was
you know i used to um whenever cars
would dry if i was playing outside and
cars were driving by i would just hide
you know because i didn't want the
people in the cars looking at me
and i can remember really vividly one
time you know some you know i've gotten
all my friends to do this like
okay we gotta hide and everyone i don't
think that was a game or something so
they're all hiding
and someone came by some other kid came
by and it's like why are you all
hiding when a car drives by you know and
i'm kind of like well why wouldn't you
hide when a car drives
by you know otherwise they're gonna see
you and um you know certainly nothing i
always wanted there to be a show like
geek's guide to the galaxy but certainly
like
nothing in my childhood made me think
that anyone wanted to
you know like liked me in that much or
wanted to hear what i had to say or
you know the idea that i could be any
kind of like host or something
was just impossible i mean it was not
something i ever would have imagined
and um i also have sort of like a um in
my whole life i had this crippling fear
of talking on the telephone
and so um you know when my mom you know
my mom would just be like okay you have
to call makeup call up and make a
doctor's appointment or something
and i'd be like can you do it and she's
like no you this is you have to get over
this you know and if you're like no
can you just just this this one time
just make the call for me yeah i don't
want to do it
and so the idea and then my job now
consists you know
mostly of calling people up on the
telephone and talking to them for an
hour an hour and a half you know
which is not something i ever would have
imagined i would do either also seems
impossible and so i mean
i think the thing is just like you know
that i would tell my younger self i mean
i would tell myself the specifics if i
could
um certainly if i had been um you know i
got into podcasting pretty early
like 2010 was pretty early but if i'd
gotten into it in 2006 i mean i think i
could have built
built up i don't know if that might be i
don't know exactly when it started but
around that you know
a couple of years earlier i could have
really really built up an audience in
those early days when there were only
like 50 podcasts on
you know on itunes or whatever um but um
but
but the broader thing i would tell
myself is just like yeah you don't know
life is long
and just because you know you don't know
what's going to happen and don't
worry too much about what you can't do
just you know do what you can and over
10 years or 20 years you know who knows
what might happen it might
turn out a lot better than you think it
will very good well that's very sage
advice
and i i i really do salute you
uh you're incredibly vulnerable person
and i love that about you i love about
your podcast the
intellectual depth that you go to uh
that you
that you find uh the most kind of
interesting questions that i always find
myself
asking i hope he asked that and then you
ask the question
that's the highest praise from one
podcaster to another not that you need
it
you're doing a phenomenal job you're an
inspiration to those of us who are
beginning our journey into podcasting
and i hope that we can continue this
relationship maybe come back on a
regular basis until the end of the
impossible podcast
so for now i ask everybody to like and
subscribe
uh both this podcast but also to the
geeks guy to the galaxy
you can go to itunes and give both a
rating it's not a zero-sum game
it's an infinite game we can all prosper
as they say live long and prosper
as they say in science fiction for now
wishing everybody out there a wonderful
weekend
of blessings and success and good health
and to you dave thank you so much for
for being our guest and going so bravely
so
boldly into the impossible thanks very
much everybody and now
i'll take you out with my friend and
good
good lover and uh of the show
and uh and and such a great contributor
so gracious
miguel tully yeti tears the into the
impossible
outro now playing signing off do we do
one of these dave do we do one of these
that's for sure okay thrive and survive
and be well everybody out there thank
you so much for going into the
impossible
until next time next week we'll have on
carlo rovelli
let me know if you want to have him in
the live stream like we did with dave
out there send me a comment on this
channel
in the chat box and i will try to
arrange that
and then stay tuned for many many other
guests including maybe michio kaku
i'm supposed to have him on the show too
so anyway have a great weekend
thanks everybody enjoy the rest of your
day